In the last video, I gave the
example of this bank that I
keep using.
In this example, as opposed to
giving the gold out to make
loans and be used for projects
that gold gets redeposited and
then re-lent out.
What we did in this examples is
that the bank-- every time
it made a loan, it just made a
loan and that created an asset
and then it had a corresponding
liability where
the liability was either a
checking account that the
entrepreneur could use or bank
notes, which are essentially
cash that the entrepreneur
could use to pay their
laborers or to buy their land or
whatever they needed to do.
So an obvious question was, how
much could a bank do it?
When does this stop?
Can a bank just keep increasing
the left and right
hand sides of the
balance sheet?
And to answer this question,
we'll introduce the idea of a
reserve ratio.
So just, I guess, a bit of a
review, just to make sure
we're clearly reading
this balance sheet.
Let me label things a little bit
more because sometimes I
assume too much.
Remember, these are
the assets.
The assets are all of these.
Let me make a bold line here.
All of this is the assets of
this bank, including its
building, so its vault
down there.
And then the liabilities.
I'll do that in this red.
I don't like this red color, but
these are the liabilities.
And the equity-- whoever owns
the bank, whether it's
stockholders or maybe it's
owned by an individual.
Maybe it's owned by me--
is what's left over.
I'll do it in a nice
neutral color.
This is the equity.
So the question is, how much can
the bank continue to issue
out more loans and increase
its assets and its
liabilities?
Remember, every time it'd issue
a loan, like for right
here, it issued a 100 gold piece
equivalent loan to D--
and instead of giving D 100 gold
pieces from, say, right
here, it just created a checking
account for D, which
later D paid to A and that's why
it's labeled A right here.
Let me relabel another thing
because the gold is different
colors so you see the gold.
This is the gold part
of the assets.
Let me make that very clear,
that all of this
right here is gold.
That's all gold and there's
500 gold pieces.
So let's introduce the concept
of a reserve ratio.
Let's think a little bit about
what even a reserve is.
A reserve is something that
you keep aside because you
might need it one day.
And in this situation, all of
these liabilities-- whether
they're these bank notes
outstanding in this example or
whether they're these checking
accounts, these demand
accounts-- these are all
liabilities that someone can
come back to the bank on any
given day and say, hey, I want
my gold now-- for
whatever reason.
Maybe I'm leaving town.
Maybe I don't trust
the bank anymore.
For whatever reason--
maybe they just want
to make some jewelry.
For whatever reason, that person
wants their gold back.
These are demand accounts.
These checking accounts are
demand accounts and these
notes are things that can be
exchanged for gold at any
point in time.
And we talked a little bit about
this earlier when we
started the whole banking
discussion, but you have to
leave aside a little bit of
gold just in case someone
wants their gold back.
So this amount of the gold that
you have to leave aside
as a reserve, relative to the
total amount of demands you
have on that gold, that's
the reserve ratio.
And in this situation, this
world that we've created, the
reserve store value is gold.
Later on we're going to get
ourselves off of this gold
system and then that reserve
store of value is actually
going to turn into cash, but
for right now-- and I think
it's easier actually to
conceptualize gold.
Let's stick with gold.
The reserve ratio for this bank
is the amount of gold
assets-- you won't see this
formal definition anywhere
because most people are off the
gold standard right now--
but it's the amount of gold
assets divided by total-- I
don't want to say total
liabilities because the bank
could take out loans that
aren't demand loans.
Everything on the liabilities
right now are on demand loans,
which means whoever has that
liability can come back and
exchange it for gold at any
moment in time, but the bank
could've taken just a regular
loan-- and a regular loan
might not be on demand.
A regular loan might be a loan
that the bank doesn't have to
pay back for 10 years, in which
case there's no reason
why the bank would have
to set aside some
gold to pay that back.
So let's make our definition
not total liabilities, but
total demand liabilities.
So what would be total
demand liabilities?
That would be total bank notes
in this case-- and bank notes
are also something-- we'll
later leave a world where
every bank is issuing bank
notes, but I just wanted to
give you that kind of historical
context, how bank
notes even started off.
Total bank notes and
demand accounts,
demand or checking accounts.
So let's see what it is for this
bank that we have here.
So our total gold assets are
500-- and what's our total
demand accounts?
100 plus 100 plus 100-- 100,
200, 300, 400-- 600-- and I
think this is another
100 here-- 700.
The total demand liabilities,
I just figured out, was 700
and the gold assets in
this bank are 500.
So right now the reserve
ratio of this bank is
pretty high-- 5/7.
So I don't know what 5/7 is.
If I'm doing my mental math
right, it's about 62%-- 7 goes
into 50-- no, no, 7 goes into
57 times-- it's like 71%.
Right.
7 times 7 is 49-- 71%.
So that's its reserve ratio.
And what keeps banks from just
keep issuing more assets and
debts to expand its balance
sheet is a reserve ratio
requirement.
So right now in the United
States-- although we're not on
the gold standard, but you
could imagine it in this
world-- our bank regulators
might say that your reserve
ratio on demand accounts-- so
the amount of gold you have to
set aside for checking
accounts-- so reserve
requirement, we'll call it.
Let me change colors just
to ease the monotony.
They might say the reserve
requirement is equal to--
let's say they want
to be safe.
Let's say they want
to make it 20%.
In the U.S. right now, it's
10% although the reserve
commodity isn't gold anymore.
Let's say your reserve
requirement is 20%.
That means as long as-- at any
given moment in time, more
than 20% of these people don't
demand their money back, the
bank's going to have
liquidity.
The bank is going to be able
to fulfill its promise.
Because all of these people
think at any given moment they
can go to the bank and
get their gold.
In order for this system to
work, there has to be
confidence-- and in order for
there to be confidence, the
bank has to be good for it every
time someone asks for
their money.
So the bank has to
stay liquid.
So essentially this reserve
ratio is what the regulators
think that a bank needs
to maintain
in order to be liquid.
Our bank as it is right now, it
has a reserve ratio of 71%.
So as long as no more than 71%
of these people-- some of
these loans, they might be
out for a year or two.
So as long as, in that year or
two that these loans are out,
as long as no more than 71% of
these people don't come asking
for their gold, we
should be OK.
If all of a sudden for whatever
weird reason, I don't
know, 80% of these people who
have demand deposits or bank
notes come and want to switch
their money for gold, this
bank is going to run out of gold
and that's a bank run.
And there's a couple of reasons
why that's really bad.
One is, all of a sudden these
demand deposit accounts all of
a sudden don't seem to be that
great because you're not
really getting your gold on
demand because more people are
asking for gold than
there is gold.
And the other problem is, all of
a sudden everyone will lose
confidence in the system and
everyone's going to think,
boy, these banks that have
these nice vault-looking
buildings-- maybe they're not
as safe as I thought.
So everyone is going to start
pulling their money out.
And that's called a bank run.
So in this example, if I assume
that this loan is
really worth 300 gold pieces
and it's really going to be
paid back and this loan right
here is really worth 100 gold
pieces and it really
will be paid back,
this bank is solvent.
It has more assets than
it does liabilities.
So if it has enough time, it
will be able to pay back all
of its liabilities.
But if all of these people, all
of a sudden, come in and
want not just 500 gold pieces,
if they want 600 gold pieces,
right, they're owed actually
700-- so if they want 600 gold
pieces, all of a sudden
everyone's going to lose
confidence in the system.
These people probably-- if
they're not able to get that,
they're probably going to want
all their money back so then
all of these liabilities
are going to come due.
And then maybe the bank is going
to have to try to sell
these loans to someone else or
maybe try to collect from
someone, but as you can imagine,
it's a big mess and
the whole system which is
dependent on confidence will
just start to crumble.
But anyway, the initial question
is, what is the limit
to how much you can expand the
asset and the liability side
of the balance sheet just by
creating these loans and these
deposit accounts?
And that limit is driven by the
reserve ratio, whatever
the regulators set.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.